"Two and a Half Men" was one of the biggest
hits in sitcom history. But the series finale
was missing one of its biggest stars
for a very specific and unique reason:
he didn't want to be crushed to death by a piano.
So what did Charlie Sheen want instead? Well,
to understand the power struggle that led
to Sheen's absence from the series finale,
first you have to understand the
decade of craziness that preceded it.
When the show debuted on CBS in 2003,
it was an instant hit. Both Sheen
and co-star Jon Cryer were 80s icons
reinventing themselves for a new millennium.
And it worked. Cryer told Entertainment Weekly
"Charlie and I really hit it off. We
had a great first few years on that
show. It was incredibly smooth, we had a
lovely time, it was working really well."
And then it suddenly stopped working well,
as Sheen famously and spectacularly went
off the rails. The tipping point was
reportedly Sheen's 2005 divorce from
Denise Richards. According to Cryer,
that's when Sheen turned to drugs.
"At first he could handle it, and he was still
incredibly professional — and still lovely,
by the way, to everybody on set — but you
could just see that stuff was wearing on him."
It was just the kind of trouble
the show had been hoping to avoid,
as Sheen had been a tabloid regular in the 1990s.
"Two and a Half Men" producer Chuck
Lorre took a chance on Sheen anyway,
writing the role of Charlie Harper for Sheen.
But following his divorce from Richards, Sheen
began making headlines again for all the wrong
reasons. He was accused of hiring sex workers,
arrested on assault charges, and sentenced to
rehab and anger management among other things.
Finally, in 2011, during Season 8 of "Two
and a Half Men," the show went on hiatus so
that Sheen could deal with his problems.
Instead, he refused to enter a facility,
fired his private sobriety coach, and
verbally attacked Lorre. That was the end:
Lorre fired him, and Sheen responded with a
typically unhinged statement, telling TMZ,
"This is very good news. They continue to
be in breach, like so many whales. It is a
big day of gladness at the Sober Valley Lodge
because now I can take all of the bazillions,
never have to look at [them] again
and I never have to put on those
silly shirts for as long as this warlock
exists in the terrestrial dimension."
Sheen wasn't exactly contrite about his drug
fueled antics in later interviews either.
"I don't know, man, I was banging
seven gram rocks and finishing them
because that's how I roll. I have
one speed, I have one gear: GO!"
"Two and a Half Men" survived Sheen's departure by
killing off Charlie Harper and replacing
him with new character Walden Schmidt,
played by Ashton Kutcher. The show ran
several more seasons before ending in 2015.
Which is where the piano comes in.
Even though Charlie Harper was dead, producers
hoped to bring back Sheen for the series finale.
The idea was that Charlie would ring the
doorbell, then rant to the camera about
drug abuse and how he was above all that.
Then, a piano would fall from the sky,
killing him. It would be very meta,
and thus fit the humor of the show.
However, Sheen had something totally different
in mind. He was willing to appear in the finale,
but he wanted his character's return to
be a launching pad for a proposed new
spinoff series called "The Harpers,"
which would have reunited him with
Cryer. When the producers didn't go
for his idea, he refused to appear.
So instead, the producers simply ran the scene
anyway, only with a body double for the absent
Sheen. And they added a coda where Lorre
poked fun at both Sheen and himself as well.
"Winning."
It was a weird end to Sheen's tenure on "Two
and a Half Men," but not the end of his career
or his personal growth. In 2021 he told Yahoo!
Entertainment that he regretted how things went.
"There was 55 different ways for me to handle
that situation, and I chose number 56. And so,
you know, I think the growth for me post-meltdown
or melt forward or melt somewhere — however
you want to label it — it has to start with
absolute ownership of my role in all of it."